I started thinking about it when people
said like you know you think could you
beat like twelve twelve year olds a [ __ ]
up twelve twelve year old okay
sure maybe hundred percent what if
they're organized I don't they don't
have a chance they don't have a chance
if they all come at you at once no they
don't care about getting beat up
first of all everybody cares about
getting beat up you're talking about
nonhumans now well I'm but if you start
training them at a young age I'm gonna
[ __ ] them up you don't have a chance
the first ones going to get kicked into
a girl is getting a kick hard for sure
and the only one we got to panic and
then I'm just going to start smashing so
okay okay I listen if I had a fight me
and ten other dudes went to fight a
500-pound man that's more coyotes [ __ ] I
was a weird-looking one yes I'll bury
you bury I eat a lot of berries yeah if
I had to get ten friends yeah and we had
to fight a 500-pound hulking man yeah I
would be [ __ ] who'd be [ __ ] we'd be
[ __ ] we didn't have a chance
what about 12 like Duncan Trussell could
you take that little bit bigger now his
current form hurt more absolutely all up
we'd have a chance by the beard one of
them in front of me at some point
the problem with Duncan is he wouldn't
be able to really do any damage if he
got close he could punch you square in
the jaw you'd laugh it up like beard
Baracus yeah you'd be like okay but if
you had a deal with like three Bert
Kreischer
right I'm probably gonna get [ __ ] up
yeah
even if he's not a trained fighter the
first guy you have to take out
immediately hard as hard as you can you
also have to show consequences for
everybody else
well we smoked way too much pot for this
pot I believe it was the right amount